bonsoir
vous êtes à moscou que retenir de cette
conférence en commun des deux dirigeants
oui cette conférence de presse qui vient
à l'instant de se terminer vous pouvez
voir la salle est vide derrière moi et
donc après près de six heures
d'entretiens les deux hommes se sont
présentés face à la presse chaque partie
a bien entendu fait valoir sa position à
chaque fois très différentes sur les
différents sujets que compte et et les
garanties russe de demandes de ces que
les demandes de garanties de sécurité de
la part de la russie mais aussi bien
entendu le coeur du problème que ce
qu'est l'ukraine et le conflit dans
l'est du pays la dir poutine regrette
par exemple que les autorités russes que
les autorités ukrainiennes ne dialogue
pas directement avec les autorités de
lougansk et de deux nièces qui
faciliterait d'après lui beaucoup les
choses pour moscou en effet kiev
s'attelle à démanteler jour après jour
ces accords de minsk écoutez
j'ai attiré l'attention de monsieur le
président
sur la réticence des autorités de kiev
de respecter leurs obligations deux
accords de minsk et notamment et qui
avait été confirmée à paris et à berlin
aujourd'hui c'est clair que les
autorités de kiev cherche aujourd'hui à
saboter ses accords de minsk sur des
questions importantes comme la la
réforme constitutionnelle amnistie
le statut particulier de dans deux bars
et la législation russe ukrainienne n'a
toujours pas
un n'a pas encore officialisé la formule
dit steinmeier
s'ils faisaient que les accords de minsk
proposait donc un certain nombre de
concessions étaient proposées de son
côté emmanuel macron a déclaré qu'il
fallait travailler rapidement car la
situation était plus que tendue pour
trouver des éléments de convergence et
ce pour éviter toute escalade alors que
cette région est largement militarisé
d'un côté comme de l'autre de la
frontière le président français on
l'aura compris à une lecture toute
différente de la situation en ukraine et
dans le donbass écoutez le troisième
sujet sur lequel nous avons acté des
éléments de convergence et d'exigence
même si j'ai noté que dans son propos le
président est surtout revenu sur les
éléments de préoccupation et le
règlement du conflit russo ukrainien
je me rendrai demain à kiev pour
rencontrer le président zelensky et nous
sommes évidemment parfaite coordination
sur ce point avec le chancelier olaf
scholz avec lequel je me suis
étroitement coordonnées il ya quelques
jours et que je retrouverai demain en
fin d'après midi à ben
nous poursuivons nos efforts au sein du
format normandie en vue de la pleine
mise en oeuvre des accords de minsk et
d'une résolution durable du conflit dans
le donbass
la dernière réunion des conseillers
format normandie a permis d'acter le
soutien inconditionnel de l'ensemble des
parties prenantes au respect du
cessez-le-feu ce qui est une avancée
réelle et nous souhaitons bâtir sur
cette dynamique afin d'avancer de
manière très concrète et de continuer la
mise en oeuvre de ces accords
strictement et en totalité et nous
sommes revenus sur plusieurs points
techniques durant la discussion je veux
ici saluer les efforts faits par le
président et nude qui en particulier des
engagements clairs qu'il a pris dans ce
format et vis-à-vis de nous tous de
retirer les lois qu'ils n'étaient pas
conformes
justement aux accords de minsk puisque
les lois évoquée par le président
poutine ont bien été retirés à
l'initiative du président céline ce qui
de la même manière que le président
poutine a pu m'apporter plein de
clarifications sur les rumeurs qui
courent de loi qui serait ici déposée
qui ne serait pas non plus conforme à
ces accords il n'en serait pas du tout
question non plus sur la base de cette
situation qualifiée nous devons
continuer à avancer nous réengager c'est
essentiel pour la paix et la stabilité
en europe car ce conflit est au coeur
des tensions que nous vivons aujourd'hui
et il est nécessaire de parvenir à un
règlement qui permettrait que la russie
et l'union européenne puis serait
engagée fortement leurs relations pour
emmanuel macron le conflit dans l'est de
l'ukraine n'est pas une guerre chaude
mais ici une situation de tension
extrême il faut donc trouver des
solutions nouvelles et pour ce faire il
a promis de consulter l'ensemble de ses
partenaires que ce soit à washington ou
encore dans le reste de l'union
européenne afin de trouver des solutions
concrètes qui puissent convenir à tout
le monde emmanuel macron l'a promis ces
prochains jours ces prochaines semaines
seront décisifs merci antoine claireaux
pour ces précisions depuis moscou